bonsoir madame Hogan bonsoir alors sur
les vaccins on vient d'en parler là
contre la covid-19 quel est votre
évaluation globale de la gestion qui a
été faite par le gouvernement fédéraltan
en matière d'approvisionnement qu'au
chapitre de la distribution
alors dans notre vie sur les vaccins
nous avons vérifié
trois ministères et nous avons conclu
que les mystères ont bien travaillé
ensemble pour répondre
à l'urgence de la pandémie ainsi que la
situation qui évoluait
le gouvernement a pris une décision pour
conclure cette entente entre anticipé
qui a assuré que chaque Canadien qui
voulait se faire vacciner avait accès à
un vaccin mais
le résultat était qu'il y a des
vaccins excédentaires et certains
vaccins ont se sont rendus à leur date
d'expiration en stockage et non pas
administré ou donner à d'autres pays bon
c'est une bonne chose vous dites d'une
part parce qu'on a pu protéger tout le
monde qui souhaitait l'être mais en
contrepartie on dispose non seulement de
toutes les doses nécessaires et plus
encore vous dites près de 51 millions de
doses jugés excédentaires est-ce que
l'Agence de la santé publique est-ce que
Santé Canada font suffisamment d'efforts
madame Hogan pour faire le don de ces
doses de vaccins avant qu'ils soient
périmés
alors nous avons constaté que l'Agence
de la santé publique du Canada aurait pu
faire d'autres mesures pour minimiser le
gaspillage la première serait de
d'utiliser toutes les fonctionnalités du
logiciel vaccine Connect pour qui était
mise en place pour aider avec la gestion
des vaccins
il y a des fonctionnalités qui n'ont pas
été utilisées et qui aurait pu améliorer
l'estimer des besoins et aussi savoir si
les vaccins allaient expirer mais il
faut pas oublier la situation dans
laquelle le pays était il est la
décision en 2020 de conclure cette
entente anticiper était une qui était
prudente mais le marché de dons est
aussi saturé et alors le pays a vraiment
un peu de difficulté à donner les
vaccins excellentaires en temps très
bien votre deuxième rapport et peut-être
un peu plus critique que vous êtes
penché sur la gestion des prestations
liées à la covid-19 on s'en souvient
très bien c'était l'urgence il fallait
choisir de faire confiance au canadiens
pour leur verser de l'aide financière
rapidement sans trop vérifié leur
admissibilité au préalable est-ce que
c'était justifié dans le contexte
des milliards qui mériteraient une
enquête pourquoi au moins est-ce que la
somme pourrait être encore plus
importante madame Hogan oui à notre avis
il pourrait avoir d'autres sommes qui
s'ajouteraient à le 27,4 milliards de
dollars mais au moins est à cause du
fait que le gouvernement vraiment pas
demandé beaucoup d'informations lors que
par exemple les entreprises
faisaient la demande de subvention
salariale il y a très peu d'informations
en ce moment à l'agence de revenus du
Canada et alors sans cette information
là et il est difficile de conclure et
c'est pour cela que nous avons
recommandé que le gouvernement fait un
suivi plus accru avec tous les
contribuables et les entreprises à
risque de ne pas être éligible aux
prestations qu'ils ont reçu est-ce que
le gouvernement en fait assez au moment
où on se parle l'Agence du revenu pour
récupérer les sommes qui pourraient lui
être dues
alors ce que nous avons mentionné dans
notre vie c'est que le gouvernement a
retardé leur plan de paiement de
post-varification à cause du fait que le
pandémie continuait mais il y a un délai
pour être en mesure de d'identifier
d'aviser les contribuables et les
entreprises s'ils doivent redonner de
l'argent et ses délais approchent très
vite et c'est pour ça que nous
encourageons le gouvernement de vraiment
faire plus de travaux immédiatement pour
faire le suivi avec les entreprises et
les contribuables quand vous parlez de
ce délai qui approche rapidement on
disait tout à l'heure trois ans entre le
moment où l'aide est demandé et le
moment où on peut vérifier
l'admissibilité donc pour les premières
prestations ça nous mène au printemps
2023 c'est dans quelques mois ça madame
Hogan est-ce que c'est réaliste de
penser que l'Agence du revenu pourrait
tout récupérer
c'est beaucoup de travail et le
gouvernement est le savait en 2020 quand
tu as pris la décision de limiter l'épée
les contrôles préalables au paiement et
c'est ils ont répondu à nos
recommandations en 2021 lors de mes deux
premières années sur les prestations
qu'ils allaient mettre en place des
plans exhaustives et ce qu'on va en ce
moment c'est que ce n'est pas le cas il
y a beaucoup plus de travail qui est de
besoin et c'est certain que le travail
va prendre du temps mais la première
étape est vraiment d'identifier les
contribuables et les entreprises
inadmissibles puis après la décision de
de recouvrer les paiements est un que si
le gouvernement veut prendre une
approche différente renoncer par exemple
de recouvrer certains paiements il
devrait être clair et transparent avec
les Canadiens très bien Madame Hogan
vérificatrices général du Canada merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI